So. 2016 ist dabei, 2016, doch es kommt 2017! Stefan Titzler ist heute mit dabei und Flo und den Willenorek ist dabei. In der letzten Folge des Jahres 2016, ein letztes Mal sind wir hier zusammengekommen in unserem neuen... Behaglich!
Ach Gott, wir müssen die Heizung ausmachen. Hashtag Behaglichkeit heute. Das ist die letzte Anmoderation, in der wir uns gerade befinden, des Jahres. Ja, und ihr könnt es euch auch so vorstellen, unser Studio ist komplett leer geräumt. Alles, was übrig geblieben ist, ist nur noch ein Tisch und zwei Mikrofone, mit denen wir es auf Hogwarts, in diesen Shots, wo es danach in die Ferien geht, Weihnachten, wo die noch Schach spielen im ersten Teil und im Hintergrund schon die ganzen Leute mit Koffern stehen. Der Flur ist voller Leute mit Koffern, die sich gerade Hände drücken, Hände ringend in den Armen liegen, was auch immer das ist, und die Sweater berühren sich, was so ein Knautschgeräusch gibt. Was für die Tontechniker ein enormes Problem war bei den Dreharbeiten von Harry Potter. Schwierig. Und dann stehen Leute auf dem Flur und gehen jetzt nach Hause langsam. Habe ich ein Gain oder was? Ach ja. Wie war dein Jahr? Wie war dein Jahr? Wie war dein 2016? Ach ja, 2016 hat natürlich eine Menge Änderungen mit sich mitgebracht. Es hat eine Menge Schwierigkeiten. Der große Umstieg natürlich, unser neuer YouTube-Kanal ist gestartet, Funk ist gestartet. Vermisst du das Neomagazin? Manchmal schon, also die Aufzeichnungen auf jeden Fall schon, es war immer so ein Event und dann sogar Schlagzeug ist laut. Und das Essen war immer toll. Aber so ein Schlagzeug ist richtig laut, wenn du da im Studio stehst und denkst dir, ja mein Gott, Leute reden, habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Diese Schlagzeuge, du denkst dir, um Gottes Willen, das ist lauter. Und die besseren Schlagzeuge, die klingen ja nicht besser, die sind einfach nur lauter. Ja. Sie sind viele nicht. Ja, ich kann mich noch ganz dunkel an meinen Kindergarten erinnern, wo wir auch mal so ein Vater von einem Kindergartenkind, wie sagt man eigentlich, Kamerad, Genosse im Kindergarten, ich weiß gar nicht, was man sagt, Kollege, Kollegus. Kindergarten. Ich glaube, Kollege einfach, oder ein Kollege im Kindergarten. Kommilitone. Ein Vater eines Kommilitonen hat Schlagzeug gespielt und der ist eines Tages einfach aufgetaucht. Und dann waren wir alle in der Turnhalle und er war in der Mitte der Turnhalle und hat Schlagzeug gespielt. Und die Kinder standen alle so ganz am Rand gedrückt, so um die Turnaußen an der Turnhalle rum und haben sich alle die Ohren zugehalten und manche haben geschrien, weil es so laut war und der in der Mitte so, so kriegen der jetzt mal Schlagzeuge und der drrrr und alle so in den Arm brechen zusammen. Wenn dann noch so eine übertriebene Show aus dem Nichts mit Pyro, also bekommt das jetzt der Ernst, von der Decke Riesen aus dem Goldträgen. Die Laura fängt an zu brennen, einfach läuft durch die Gegend furchtbar an. Aber ich finde das auch mal, wenn Unterhaltung nach hinten losgeht und dann schreien die Kinder. Es ist so laut. Das war wirklich traumatisch, ich kann mich da immer noch daran erinnern, dass es sehr unangenehm war und alle so die Ohren zugemacht haben. Ja, und so ein damaliger Schlagzeuger, der hatte einen Knalltrauma. Und zwar hatte er eine Mittelohrentzündung als Baby zu Silvester und das war wohl so laut und so schlimm für ihn in den Ohren, dass er einen Knalltrauma davon getragen hat und als Therapie hat er angefangen, Schlagzeuge zu spielen, um sich selber zu therapieren und er hat auch immer so zusammengezuckt, wenn er auf die Snare gehauen hat. Das war unsere Choreo immer so. Alter, Biggie sagt, Wum ist die beste Band aller Zeiten gewesen, er war komplette Vollbehinderte so ein Inklusionsband. Downy, System of Down.
Schlagzeuge hat einen Knalltrauma, der Gitarrist nur eine Hand,
der Keyboarder hat keinen Kopf mehr.
Hey, we don't give a fuck!
Übrigens, unter anderem könnt ihr euch 2017 auch freuen
auf die grosse Binky-Sagt-Boo-Podcast-Folge.
Da könnt ihr noch eure... Ist das so interessant?
Weißt du, wir erwähnen irgendwie irgendeinen so einen Scheiss
nebenbei, weil wir sagen mal, ja, ich glaube, irgendwo
in Ägypten gab es mal Stonehenge und wir
kriegen 50 Dokus geschickt
und wirklich Referate
und so PDFs, die jemand zusammengestellt
Vielen Dank. weil wir sagen mal, ja, ich glaube, irgendwo in Ägypten gab es mal Stonehenge und wir kriegen 50 Dokus geschickt und wirklich Referate und so PDFs, die jemand zusammengestellt hat, so mit Farben und so zum Thema Ägypten und Stonehenge und so. Aber wenn wir mal wirklich aufrufen, hey, schickt uns Fragen zu Bing und gesagt, boop, nichts, gar nichts, wenn wir beim anderen Podcast irgendwie Suggestions wollen für Wörter, auf Basis dessen, der Podcast erst funktioniert, nope.
Gar nichts. Als wir gesagt haben, ich spende an die Krebshilfe, nichts.
Ich stelle mir einen Improabend vor,
wo wir da stehen und sagen, ja und, was ist
euer Wort?
Leute, irgendwas, irgendwas.
Publikum sagt nichts die ganze Zeit und
es kommt nicht zustande. Okay,
habe ich da David Bowie gehört, alles klar.
Dann bauen sie ganz traurig alles wieder ab und gehen einfach nach Hause und so und kriegen das Geld zurückgezahlt werden, weil es einfach nicht funktioniert. Ja, wir haben mit Impro-Podcast angefangen, auch ein lang gehickter Traum von uns beiden. Wir waren in New York dieses Jahr auch. Das war ein Highlight dieses Jahr. Das war ein absolutes Highlight. Ja, New York war super. An was erinnerst du dich am liebsten an New York? Ich weiß nicht, an das so Rumgelümmel und Rumgelaufe, so die Strassen und die Fassaden, ich schaue gerade auch Seinfeld und so, das ist einfach so viel geil, ich wäre da gerne gerade. Ich war gerne im Supermarkt, das war ein großes Event für mich. Der Supermarkt war unglaublich, die Menschen, die Menschen, oder der Markt hat, und dann sind wir, wie wir dann abends an dem Hudson rüber noch alleingelaufen sind, Hand in Hand, zum Laternenlicht. Und ich fand, Lee Miserable war ein tolles Erlebnis für mich. Toller Song. Toller Song. Toller Songs. Impro war richtig geil, war für mich ein Comedy Katalysator dieses Jahr. Diese Impro-Sachen, die wir da haben, ist auch Stand-Up und so. Wir haben Louis C.K. gesehen
dieses Jahr. Wahnsinnig
tolle Dinge, wir haben tolle Leute kennengelernt.
Ja, war toll.
Wir wurden beim New Magazin rausgeschmissen, haben uns unseren
eigenen mittelmässig laufenden YouTube-Kanal
mit, wir machen da so Vlogs und
Let's Plays und sowas in der Richtung.
Das läuft so, geht so.
Ja, ein bisschen anstrengend.
Naja, 2017 finde ich vor allem spannend, was das du für Pläne? Ich habe zum Beispiel Lust, habe ich ja schon oft gesagt, Stand-Up zu machen. Ab März will ich richtig durchstarten, glaube ich funktioniert gar nicht. Warum hast du dir gerade März ausgesucht? Also so oft sind ja so Vorsätze dann direkt ab Januar. Nee. Aber du hast direkt gesagt, so ja, war ich nicht. Ich bin Kuffer. Ich habe jetzt gerade, ich bin so faul, ich bin einfach so müde. Ich bin seit Wochen nur noch müde und ich bin zumindest mehr als müde. Und ab dann kann ich durchstarten mit sowas. Das ist, glaube ich, was ich durchstarten will. Ich würde auch gerne mal eine Serie, eine Sitcom umsetzen oder sowas. Cool, macht man ja nicht alles. Nee, macht man ja nicht. Schieben ja die meisten vor sich, also mal eine Sitcom schreiben, macht man ja eh nicht. Das kennt man ja. Ich meine, die meisten Hörer draußen haben eine halbe Effibristen in der Schublade, aber schreiben sie nicht zu Ende. Warum nicht, Leute? Schreiben sie zu Ende. Das ist Literaturgold, was da liegt. Da ist der Literatur-Nobelpreis. Liegt in eurer Schublade zu Hause. Macht die mal, macht die mal zu Ende. Was sind deine Vorsätze? Ach, oh gut, ich habe mir nachgedacht, so ein bisschen mehr. Das ist einem schneller Dinge einfallen, vielleicht.
Ja, dass ich ein bisschen kreativer bin,
dass ich bessere Vorsätze habe für 2018.
Das ist mein Vorsatz,
dass ich mir im Laufe des Jahres bessere Vorsätze überlege.
Ne, ansonsten läuft es eigentlich
ganz gut so weit.
Ich schlafe recht wenig
die letzten Monate,
das ist mir aufgefallen,
aber da kann ich jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel dran ändern.
Ja, wie viel Rumpfvögel ist, oder?
Alter, Roxale, mir! Du, schlafen kann ich jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel dran ändern.
Alter,
Roxaleme!
Du, schlafen kann ich noch, wenn ich tot bin, sage ich.
Sage ich sehr selten. Ja, das ist ausgesprochen selten.
Aber geht es ja nicht auch so,
dass, obwohl das komplett paradox
ist, dass man
das Gefühl hat, dass ab Januar,
also ab dem 31.12. was Neues beginnt. Ja, obwohl es einfach arbiträr ist, dass man das alles ja startet. Ja, es ist komplett Quatsch, also das ist einfach, hat irgendwer entschieden, dass genau da der Punkt ist, an dem die Erde steht, wo das ja dann neu beginnt, aber da ist ja keine Mauer, durch die die Erde geht oder so, sondern es geht einfach weiter, man hat das Gefühl, ab jetzt muss ich neuer Mensch sein. So, das ist das Jahr, in dem ich 23 werde, Das ist das Jahr, was jetzt beginnt, da muss ich Kredit mehr leisten. Man macht sich selber ein bisschen verrückt. Ich glaube, es ist ein neuer Start. Ich glaube, es ist für Menschen wichtig, solche Zyklen zu haben. Einfach zu sagen, es ist ein neuer Start, ich kann mal irgendwas hinter mir lassen und dann nochmal neu anfangen. Ich glaube, das ist sehr wichtig. Tatsächlich ist ja rein psychologisch gesehen die christliche Beichte eine sehr gute Idee, weil Menschen, die beichten, schlicht und einfach moralischer leben, weil sie immer wieder von vorne anfangen können. Weil jemand, der nicht irgendwie beichtet, der bringt irgendwie einmal irgendwie eine Katze um oder so, dann sagt er, na gut, ich bin eh verloren. Ist das Beichten nicht ein Freifahrtschein, nicht moralisch zu leben? Naja, aber du kriegst ja immer wieder eine neue Chance. Ja, von wem? Von einer Instanz, die du dir ausgedacht hast? Nö, aber trotzdem, das hat ja trotzdem Wert. Wenn du die Leute sagen, so existiert das ja trotzdem. Wenn du das gesagt bekommst, deine Sünden sind vergeben, dann hat das ja... Mein Unmut will irgendwo hin. Ich habe in meinem TED-Talk oder sowas gesehen darüber, dass es eine gute Idee ist, dass wenn man Leuten immer wieder eine neue Chance gibt, sie sich dann zumindest mal irgendwie eine Woche lang
anstrengen und dann zumindest gut sind,
dann wieder schlecht werden, ist ja klar, aber
zumindest man diese Woche gewinnt, was insgesamt
auf ein ganzes Leben gewirkt, richtig, richtig
viel Zeit, richtig viel Asche. Ja, aber du kannst ja einmal
ein T-Shirt drücken oder
ein Tattoo stechen, wo zu dir geschrieben
draufsteht, dass du nach
dem kategorischen Imperativ
leben soll, sondern dass du auch ein besseres Leben
sind. Es gibt auch viel bessere Methoden als fucking
Beichte, wo du dir halt, das ist doch ein Freifahrtsschein,
Ich bin ein draufsteht, dass du nach dem kategorischen Imperativ leben soll, sondern dass du auch ein besseres Leben. Das sind doch viel bessere Methoden als fucking Beichte. Wo du dir halt, das ist doch ein Freifahrtsschein, um Scheiss zu machen. Du kannst ja auch morden, du kannst ja allen Scheiss machen und danach sagen, ich habe übrigens, leider habe ich gemordet. Aber guck mal, das Schulsystem, die Schulklassen, war doch auch immer so, du hast das Jahr verkackt und dachtest dir, gut, das Jahr ist verloren, Scheiss drauf und hast gegen Ende ihnen nur noch Schwachsinn gemacht. Aber beim nächsten Jahr hast du mir gesagt, okay, jetzt wird es wieder gut. Stell dir mal vor, die Schule wäre ein, aber stell dir mal vor, die Schulzeit wäre ein langes Schuljahr gewesen. Dann würdest du irgendwann nach zwei Monaten, hättest du keinen Bock mehr. Nein, nach zwei, ach komm, hab ich jetzt schon keinen Bock mehr. Weißt du, auf dich habe ich auch keinen Bock mehr. Ich habe mir jetzt ein Jahr lang deine Scheiße gegeben. Hier jede Woche diesen, eh, eh, Krätzeis, nee, nee, nee, mir passieren so viele verrückte Sachen. Ja, Boosted Board, der Titzler, der Titzler, ich kann es nicht mehr hören, es reicht mir unter jedem fucking Video, in jedem Kommentar, der Titzler, der Titzler, der hätte ich mir einen Titzler erwartet, mein Gott, man muss auch mal Schluss machen, man muss auch mal sagen, es reicht. Wem sagt es mal, das ist mir oder wem sagt es mal? Ja, immer diese Wiederholung. Ich schreibe die Kommentare doch nicht. Weißt du, was ich mir gerne wünschen würde für 2017? Von mir? Mehr Originalität. Von wem denn? Nicht immer, von allen einfach mal. Okay. Einfach nicht mal immer, einfach mal nicht mehr dieses konstante Wiederholen. Das hat mich, glaube ich, 2016 am meisten genervt, ist dieses konstante Wiederholen. Wir hatten The Force Awakens, Wiederholung, wir hatten Rogue One, haben wir auch schon alles gesehen, wir haben alles, wird alles so tot getrieben und immer, ich meine, das war jetzt natürlich auch last September in Monaco, ja, wo ich jede Woche den gleichen Scheiß gesehen habe, aber es wirkt wie so eine Mühle, es ist immer dasselbe und dann immer die gleichen Posts und dann kommt wieder, jetzt macht man sein Profilbild in Frankreich und dann in Türkei und dann die ganzen Tone und immer die gleichen Gags. Das sind immer dieselben Argumente. Man darf jetzt nicht irgendwie von Fundamentalisten und dann geht es wieder von Frau Lose und das ist doch kein Problem, das ist doch kein Problem von 2016. Och Gott. Das ist doch kein Problem von 2016, das ist ein Problem von allen Jahren. So das Ding, ich finde, 2006 hat ein bisschen Abwechslung reingebaut, es sind viele Menschen gestorben, das war ein Neuanfangjahr. Nein, das war das Empire Strikes Back der Jahre. So, okay, jetzt sterben erstmal alle. Denkt euch neue Prominente aus. Denkt euch neue, wir brauchen einen neuen Prince, wir brauchen einen neuen David Bowie, wir brauchen einen neuen, wer ist doch gestorben? Karl Lagerfeld, weiß ich nicht. Wir brauchen neue Menschen einfach. Das tauscht mal die Prominenten aus. Und dein Julia-Ding ist ein cooler, okay, cooles Bit. Hey, Leute lachen darüber bestimmt. Ich bin zweifelstark. Aber auf der anderen Seite, die Zeit, wo du am Ende deine Rumslacks, und ich benimm's wie das letzte Arschloch, die gleicht so aus, in dem ersten einviertel Jahr, wo du dich wieder anstrengst, weil du neuer Jahr angefangen hast. Ja, aber wenn du ein langes Jahr hättest, das gleicht sich ja aus. Nein, wenn du ein langes Jahr hättest, würdest du nur noch zwei Monate in der Gosse liegen und dann einfach weitermachen, weil du denkst, meine ganze Schulaufbahn ist verruiniert. Und wenn du neu anfangen kannst, sagst du so, jetzt aber. Das ist, ich glaube, der Mensch, man muss, ich glaube, das ist die grundsätzliche Essenz des Lebens ist. Man muss eine gesunde Harmonie zwischen Wiederholung und Innovation finden. Gewisse Dinge haben zyklische Natur, sind gut, wenn sie sich wiederholen, aber man muss auch mal sagen, jetzt, ich höre jetzt mal auf mit dem Scheiß. Ich war jetzt
genau, ich war jetzt die Witzfigur, ich war
jetzt der lange, lustige Typ mit
der Brille, der irgendwie so eine peinliche Band
hatte. Und eine albane Frisur.
Und dann lachen alle wieder drüber und mit meinem
Boosted Board und ich bin, ich nehme mich nicht ernst,
damit mich niemand auslachen kann und so.
Einfach mal sagen, nee, nächstes Jahr
ändere ich mal ein bisschen. Aber da kommt ja auch jetzt nicht viel, da kann man ja nicht viel von mir, da wird ja viel reinprojiziert. Auch von dir, auch von Figuren wie dir, die mir den Titzler aufprojizieren oder das Boosted Board zum zehnten Mal ansprechen und auch sagen, okay, für den Tinn ist doch jetzt mal gut. Du hast nur mal tausend Euro dafür ausgegeben. Ich wollte es jetzt nicht nochmal erwähnen. Taui, Taui hast du da auch nicht. Nein, nein, das sagen wir dazu nicht. Weniger Versprecher wünsche ich mir. Rundumillo. Ich wünsche mir weniger Versprecher nächstes Jahr. Stichwort Innovation. Man kann Duschflaschen verschenken, wo vorne so ein Bild drauf ist von dir. Und das ist ein ganz tolles Geschenk, was ich immer von meiner kleinen Cousine bekommen habe, was immer ein ganz tolles Gefühl ist, wenn man in der Dusche steht, an sich selber rumspielt und dann halt seine kleine siebenjährige Cousine einen anguckt, auf dem großen Duschdassel. So beschämt die Flasche umdrehst du. Jetzt nicht, Nina. Gleich kannst du wieder gucken. Die einfach abgeklebt hat oder mit Edding oder das Etikett abgerissen hat oder so. Oder die so Augen hingemalt hat, die zur Seite guckt. Das ist so ein tolles, das finde ich, oder ich finde das aber, man steht da drunter irgendwie frohe Weihnachten oder Happy Birthday oder so, aber wenn ihr da direkt drunter schreibt sowas wie, ich sehe dich beim Duschen oder sowas und dann, das finde ich ein tolles Geschenk, euch selbst mit so einem bisschen gruseligen Foto, wie ihr auch so wissend guckt, wissend und leicht skeptisch und angeekelt und dann drunter schreibt, bei DM kann man die glaube ich machen, wenn man dann bei DM unter der Dusche drunter schreibt, ich sehe dich beim Duschen dann einfach. Das ist, glaube ich, ein schönes Geschenk. Macht das mal und macht ein Foto davon, was sie an uns schickt. Zentrale-at-podcast-will.org Ja, finde ich sehr gut. 2017 wird natürlich auch wieder das Jahr der Pufopedia. Die Pufopedia kommt zurück. Ich werde mich über die Feiertage ganz intensiv damit auseinandersetzen. Ich habe die besten Programmierer des Landes zusammengetrieben und wir werden die Pufopedia wieder auf ihre wackeligen Beine bringen, auf der sie vorher stand und somit einen weiteren Kosmos für euch aufbauen. Stefan Titzel wirft sich gerade die amerikanische Flagge um. Erinnerst du dich noch an der Wahlabend? Oh, der Wahlabend. Der Wahlabend. Der war toll. Bei Jan Böhmermann zu Hause. Das erste Mal, dass ich bei Jan zu Hause war, tatsächlich. Hast du die Bonifahrung vorgestellt? Ich habe es mir exakt so vorgestellt. Also wie so ein Kinderzimmer. Das ist so wie wenn, das kennt man ja so aus Serien, wenn so ein elfjähriges Mädchen getötet wird und dann die Eltern lassen dann das Zimmer genauso wie es war. Die verändern dann nichts und dann liegt der Füller noch offen da und die Playboy-Hefte lugen so ein bisschen unangenehm unterm Bett hervor. Aber man lässt es so wie es ist. Und das Gras, was die Eltern erwischt haben, liegt immer noch da. Liegt leider rum. Wir haben es schon gesehen. Ja, der riesige Dildo prangt vor dem Spiegel, aber man sagt, das gehört auch zu unserer Tochter auf eine gewisse Art. Zu meinem Sohn. Man lässt es einfach so, wie es ist, und so ist Jan Böhmans Wohnung auch. Man kommt rein und denkt sich, okay, hier wurde seit langer Zeit nicht mehr so gemacht. Die Kameras, die Kameras, hat man sich aber eben in der Wohnung vorgestellt. Ja, war wirklich cool, cooler Abend. Das ist auch schön für nächstes Jahr, Trump. Comedy-mäßig, glaube ich, sehr interessant, ganz, ganz interessante Sache. Ich freue mich auf Ton-Tweets von zwei Accounts, die doppelte Menge, zum Preis von einem. Auf jeden Fall. Und das ist, glaube ich, sehr interessant, ganz, ganz interessante Sache. Ich freue mich auf Tonnen Tweets von zwei Accounts, die doppelte Menge, zum Preis von einem. Auf jeden Fall. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon spannend, was noch nächstes Jahr so passiert. AfD kommt an die Macht. Terrormässig auch spannend, was da alles so passiert nächstes Jahr. Ich denke manchmal mittlerweile wirklich hier in Köln. Ist ja eine Großstadt, wo man auch was erwarten kann und soll. Ja, gestern war ja Bombenalarm im Kölner Hauptbahnhof, da war ich tatsächlich sogar, aber mir sind die Züge ausgefallen, musste ich schön umsteigen auf Car2Go. Du bist extra so ein bisschen, hast immer die Tasche so weggeworfen und bist gerannt. Ja, ich bin ja durch die Gegend gefahren, er wurde dann relativ schnell wieder aufgehoben, als man gemerkt hat, dass es irgendwie nur so ein Pritzelbrause war irgendwie. War ein Hund, ja ein Azores war ein Hund. Was?
Bombenhund ist ja auch die beste Idee eigentlich.
Ja, Bombenroboter ist die beste Idee.
Das ist eh so, weil ich meine, man kann ja zum Beispiel Hunde trainieren einfach.
Oder?
Dieses Gag-Wackung.
Man muss die Bombe ja nicht an sich tragen, man kann einfach einen Hund trainieren.
Das hat man im Weltkrieg auch gemacht.
Das mache ich mittlerweile auch öfter gerne. Weörst du das? Es lacht niemand darüber. Einfach mal die Gangs von 2013 nochmal auskramen. Das war 2013. Ja. Was war denn noch so? Ja, war viel, ey. Fußball irgendwas? Fußball war, EM. Habe ich überhaupt nicht mit Fußball? Da war ich im Urlaub da.
Ein langes Jahr, war richtig lang dieses Mal.
Ja, kam mir lang vor.
Aber was macht so ein Silvester?
Weil Silvester ist auch immer so spannend.
Eigentlich bin ich kein Ritual, Tradition Mensch.
Finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Aber man ist dann doch so in einem gewissen Ritus gefangen, oder?
Also Silvester und doch gerade dieses ganze Neujahr, was man über die Feiertage macht. So ein paar Macken hat jeder Mensch immer.
Ich ziehe zum Beispiel immer in einem ORPG.
Vielen Dank. Mithus gefangen, oder? Also Silvester und doch gerade dieses ganze Neujahr, was man über die Feiertage macht. So ein paar Macken hat jeder Mensch immer. Ich zog zum Beispiel immer in einem ORPG. Also egal, ob ich Zeit habe oder nicht, aber ich nehme immer meinen grossen PC mit nach Hause und zog irgendwie in Morbk. Was zogst du denn? Star Wars The Old Republic. Ah, okay. Ja, ich schaue mir jedes Jahr die Herr-der-Ringe-Trilogie an, samt sämtlichem Bonus-Material bin ich immer dabei, da kann ich mich so richtig einwickeln in so eine schöne Decke. Aber du bist auch ein Traditionsmensch. Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Ich bin noch Zeitgekappt, durch und durch. Und deswegen, Herr der Ringe, schaue ich mir immer an, bin ich immer dabei. Wahrscheinlich Prinzessin Mononoke, werde ich mir nochmal schön auf den Zahn legen. Sowas in der Richtung. Ich werde eine Menge DVDs rippen. Oh, Filmtipps, wollen wir Filmtipps für die Feiertage rausgeben? Die Podcast-Uofo-Weihnachtstipps. Auf Platz fünf, zehn. Wie heißt der Dude Who Stowed My Car? Okay, auf Platz vierzehn The Lobster. Hast du den gesehen? Ja. Auf Platz dreizehn Silent. Auf Platz 12, Swiss Army Man. Auf Platz 8, Guendo Locotaradas. Bräsidianischer Film, das ist gut. Auf Platz 7, Bibliotina, voll verhext. Und auf Platz 1, Eight Mile. Das sind unsere Weihnachtstipps.
Eine Menge Tipps dabei.
Was war dein Film des Jahres?
Oh, schwierig, schwierig, schwierig.
Ja, für Star Wars, oder?
Weiß ich nicht, was?
Star Wars?
Nee.
Echt nicht?
Ja, für guter Film, aber das ist nicht der beste Film.
War ein Film, den man schon mal so ein paar Mal gesehen hat.
Also der beste Film, ich weiß nicht, was für das Army Man hat mich mehr.
Ja, das war das Army Man fand ich auch richtig, richtig gut.
Ja, schau dich ihn auf jeden Fall noch an, der hat viel zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Ja, ich fand aber auch
Ten Cloverfield Lane, ein echt cooler Film.
War Room schon
dieses Jahr? Ne, letztes Jahr, war schon
Oscars, ne? Oscar-Verlagung.
Ja, ja, das finde ich auch
sehr cool. Oscars, ja,
schön die Nacht durchmachen. Und Golden Globes werden
diesmal moderiert von Jimmy Fallon, nicht mehr von
Ricky Gervais. Und das ist auch genau,
das ist das, was mich nervt. Die Welt geht, die Welt wird zu Jimmy Fallon. Die Welt ist ein sehr guter Mensch, ein sehr guter Mensch, ein sehr guter Mensch, ein sehr guter Mensch, ein sehr guter Mensches Rumgelache. Ich vermisse Craig Ferguson. Die Welt wird weniger wie Craig Ferguson. Du, Craig Ferguson ist weg. Vergiss es. Ja, aber auch Ricky Gervais wurde jetzt abgesetzt. Das sind diese ganzen Golden Globes. Ja gut, aber das war ja eh eine Farce. Aber die Welt wird verweichlicht. Die wird zu so einer leichten Unterhaltung. So eine ganz leichte, seltsame Nerven. Mir ist tatsächlich eher das Gegenteil aufgefallen. Und zwar mein Unwort des Jahres 2016, Satire. Ich kann Satire nicht mehr hören, ich hasse Satire mittlerweile, ich hasse das. Oh, die ganze Erdwarte haben wir auch mitgemacht. Dieses Konstante, alles muss politisch jetzt sein, zeitaktuell und Satire, Satire, Satire und immer dieses, man erhebt sich so, es ist so leicht, es ist mittlerweile zu leicht, Applaus zu bekommen. Es ist zu leicht, Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen. Du musst nur jetzt irgendwie gerade zu diesem Berlin-Scheiss irgendeinen Post rauslassen, wo wir wegen, ja nicht auf die AfD hören und du hast 120 Likes. Das ist zu leicht. Wir haben keine aufgeklärte Gesellschaft mehr, die sagt, das ist scheiße, das ist einfach nur Nonsens. So, das bringt keinem was. Man dieses Filterblasen, ich bin schon wieder verpflichtet, aber dieses Filterblasen gedöhnt, so dieses, niemanden, mit dem du gerade sprichst, wird diese Botschaft irgendwas auslösen. Alle, mit denen du gerade sprichst, wenn ich auf Twitter schreibe, ich finde die AfD doof, hat das keinen Effekt. Ja. Weil alle, die mir folgen, finden die AfD eh schon doof. So, von daher, das ist nichts, man holt sich gegenseitig einen runter, man befeuert sich gegenseitig, aber es bringt gar nichts. Ja, und das ist auch dieses Late-Nacht-Show-Profit. Man fühlt sich so toll, aber es reicht nichts. Wenn Siebenkotter da steht und 18 Minuten lang darüber redet, wie toll das Land eigentlich ist und was das Land eigentlich könnte und so, dann hat das keinen Effekt. Ja. Dann spricht er dann exakt die Leute an, die Trump gewählt haben, die schauen diese Sendung nicht. Und der kriegt immer noch jedes Mal Applaus, wenn er irgendwie was gegen Trump sagt, wo man einfach sagen kann, das bringt nichts. Das ist kein Mut, das ist kein Risiko. Aber Filterblasen ist auch so ein Ding.
Das ist mein Wort des Jahres, Filterblasen.
Weil, guck mal, das ist auch nicht wirklich was Neues.
Pre-Social-Media-mäßig wurde das
auch schon benutzt.
Wurde es nicht benutzt, aber war das auch schon Wort,
was bei den Menschen angekommen ist
im Alltag. Leute haben sich immer mit Leuten umgeben,
die tendenziell eher
Gemeinsamkeiten mit ihnen haben.
Aber es war transparenter.
Heute ist es nicht mehr transparent, weil Facebook
Vielen Dank. im Alltag. Leute haben sich immer mit Leuten umgeben, die tendenziell eher Gemeinsamkeiten mit ihnen haben.
Aber es war transparenter.
Heute ist es nicht mehr transparent, weil Facebook Ich finde es viel transparenter.
Nein, nein, nein.
Facebook ist komplett intransparent.
Facebook ist ja mittlerweile scheißegal, was du geliked hast
oder was nicht. Die können ja auch von Seiten,
die du geliked hast, die einfach die Posts nicht anzeigen.
Die schauen einfach, was genau du willst, was genau du brauchst,
was genau die Leute bezahlen, die die Werbung zahlen. Du kannst genau als Werbetreibender auf Facebook genau zahlen. Ich möchte das genau Aber es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, da kriegen. Du hast keine Ahnung mehr, warum der Post in deiner Timeline auftaucht. Also wenn du ein bisschen nachdenkst, hast du die Ahnung. Nein, duißt es einfach nicht, du kennst die Algorithmen nicht, du weißt nicht, was Facebook gerade macht. Es ist nicht transparent. Wenn du dir eine Tageszeitung kaufst, dann weißt du, ah, okay, ich bin Bildleser oder ich bin SZ-Leser. Aber das ist transparent, du hast die Entscheidung klar offen, aber das, was du bekommst, ist nicht mehr transparent. Das bei Facebook, was du bekommst, ist relativ transparent. Nee, ist überhaupt nicht transparent. Auf jeden Fall, Leute, mit denen du interagierst, Leute, mit denen du interagierst, das sind alles Dinge, die den Algorithmus befeuern und die kriegst du nochmal. Es gibt Ad-Rank, heißt der Algorithmus von Facebook und der hat drei verschiedene Prinzipien. Das eine ist Aktualität, das andere ist Affinität und das andere ist Interaktion. Ja, und Werbung, wofür halt Leute gezahlt haben. Klar. Das kriegst du eher. So, aber was kriegst du denn da?
Du kannst, da gibt es ja auch Informationen über dich preis.
So, und du weisst ja, welche Informationen du über dich preisgibst, weil du die ganze Zeit preisgibst. Wenn du ein bisschen reflektiert bist, aber nachdenkst, was du tust. Du weißt ja nicht, auf welche der Informationen du preisgibst, die sich beziehen. Was genau damit gemeint ist. Aber man meint ja mit Filterblase auch nicht unbedingt die Werbung, die dich erreicht, sondern in erster Linie die Informationsblase um dich herum. Werbung ist ein kleiner Teil davon. Aber vor allem zl doch dazu auch die Leute, deren Meinung du noch entgegen bekommst, die Zeitungen, die Medien, von denen du noch... Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt ganz lange nur Posts, Likes und Leads, die halt irgendwie eine bestimmte Meinung befeuern, wirst du irgendwann keine Posts mehr bekommen, die dieser Meinung widersprechen. Richtig. Genau, und dadurch bist du halt komplett gefangen. Du denkst aber trotzdem noch, Facebook wäre ein neutrales Medium, und auch wenn du Seiten likst, die irgendwie eine gegenteilige Meinung haben, kriegst du die irgendwann nicht mehr, weil dir genau das geliefert wird, was du lesen willst. Ja, der liegt aber die Premisse zugrunde, dass du glaubst, dass du nicht von der Existenz von Filterblasen weist. Es kommt auch an, in welchem Maße. Aber es kommt auf jeden Fall zu einer Radikalisierung von Meinung, weil du immer mehr dasselbe kriegst. Früher waren Filterblasen vor allem nicht. Das Coole an der heutigen Zeit ist, dass du dir aussuchen kannst, welcher Filterblase du bist, zum gewissen Teil. Früher. Na, das glaube ich eben nicht. Schau mal. Früher warst du in der, da sagst du dann, war deine Filterblase, war deine Familie. Du hast mit Leuten am Tisch gesetzt, die haben teilweise über Ausländer gemotzt und so und waren anderer Meinung. Aber trotzdem waren die in deiner Blase sozusagen und deswegen deine Blase war durchlässiger. Heutzutage kannst du dir, je nach was du likest, was du für Channel abonnierst bei YouTube, kannst du dir schon eher aussuchen, mit wem du, du kannst Freunde, kannst du blockieren. Dann kommt ja noch der Algorithmus dazwischen, der dir genau aussucht, was davon du kriegst. Aber der Algorithmus ist ja nicht mega undurchsichtig. So oder so, ich glaube, es ist einfach nicht mehr so transparent. Wenn dein Vater am Estisch sitzt und sagt, Aussende sind scheiße, weisst du, ah, das ist der Absender, der weiss, dass das ist und wegen, aber du weisst bei Facebook nicht immer, warum jetzt gerade dieser Post genau gerade erscheint. Und was dir damit gesagt werden soll. Oder wer dahinter steckt, wer dafür gezahlt hat, oder unter welchen Prämissen das jetzt hier genau steht. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon ein anderes Problem.
Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags.
Nein, das Jahr war nicht nur lustig.
Doch, es war schon lustig.
Es war ja richtig lustig.
Nuseke war richtig gut.
War richtig gut.
War richtig gut gefallen.
Richtig lustig.
Es hat richtig Spaß gemacht.
Kann man das eigentlich schon anschauen, das Special, was wir gesehen haben? Da freue ich mich echt drauf, die Audio zu nehmen.
Ich glaube, man hört dich lachen.
Du hast sehr laut gelacht.
Du hast ja laut Podcast-Ufo gerufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch hören kann. Ja, aber rückwärts. Für Leute, die das rückwärts hören, damit es klarer herauskommt. Du, ich bin gespannt auf das kommende Jahr. Ich erwarte viel, ich erwarte viel. Was könnte noch alles passieren? Ich meine... Hast du Vorhersagen, die Top-5-Vorhersagen? Top-5-Vorhersagen. Ich glaube, Trump wird ein cooler Präsident, also wirklich im Ernst, weil er will an der Macht bleiben. Und deswegen macht er Dinge, die nicht blöd sind, sondern macht Dinge, die ihm maximal helfen, seine Macht zu erhalten. Leider ist da Demokratie einfach ein Spaßvollerbe. Deswegen glaube ich, wäre das ein cooler Präsident, der ab und zu mal eine oder andere Schlagzeile sorgt. Oh, da habe ich mich weiter aus dem Fenster gelehnt. Ich glaube, es wird eine große Innovation im Bereich des Stroms geben. Es gibt Ende 2017 kabellosen Strom. Weit verbreitet. Das ist meine Prophezeiung. Du wirst da nichts mehr in dein Handy stecken müssen. Um es auszuladen, gibt es jetzt schon teilweise, aber es gibt es durchgehend. Es gibt kabellosen Strom. Es wird das Jahr von Tesla und anderen Elektroauto-Hörsteller. Oh ja, stimmt. Elektroautos. Weil nächstes Jahr kommt das Modell 3 auf den Markt. Das ist ein wirklich bezahlbares Modell, 38.000 Euro oder sowas. Erschwinglich. Das sind 38 Boost-Boards, das geht. Das schafft, lass den Preis bitte nicht so auf jeden Fall. Und das, damit kann man richtig lange fahren, hat ordentlich Geschwindigkeit, sieht ordentlich aus. Also macht alles das zum ersten Mal richtig, was ein Elektroauto richtig machen müsste. Das ist klar, Stefan hat Tesla-Aktien, also das ist schon ein bisschen vor. Deswegen, kauft Tesla-Aktien, kauft Autos, ist mir eigentlich egal. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der Aktienmarkt funktioniert, also am besten besten beide. Das würde mir wahnsinnig helfen. Und eine Prophezeiung. Ich glaube, Ende 2017 werden Joko und Klaas keine Rolle mehr spielen. Meine Prophezeiung. Ich weiß, es ist heiß. Es ist ein richtig heißes Eisen. Ich glaube, ich habe nächstes Jahr meinen ersten Nightwash-Auftritt. Ja, das kannst du dann genau mit dem Soundbite aus der Podcast-Folge sagen. Letztes Jahr habe ich es vorausgesagt, den stehe ich hier mit meiner Amerika-Flagge um die Schulter. Ja, das wäre interessant und auch ein bisschen uncool, aber auch interessant. Vulkane, ich glaube, Vulkane werden eine große Rolle spielen. Das stimmt. Oh, oh, oh, jetzt sage ich mal was.
Man spricht beim Finanzmarkt und Immobilienmarkt, was ja sehr eng zusammenhängt, von acht
Jahreszyklen.
Also eigentlich wäre dieses Jahr wieder die große, quasi der große Krach eigentlich
nötig gewesen.
Die Krach.
Das ist auch ein Fachbegriff aus seiner Bächlerarbeit.
Der große Kaboom. Der große Krach, der große Uiuiui, der grosse Uppsala, Moment, der kommt, glaube ich, dann nächstes Jahr. Nächstes Jahr wird es einen grossen Finanzeinbruch geben. Ja? Ja. Ja, ja, okay. Doch, nächstes Jahr im Juni, da gibt es einen grossen Einbruch, da gehen den Leuten, vor allem in China, die Augen auf, soweit es geht. Die Chinesen werden grosser Augenmangel. Also so, ne? Bin ich schlecht? Ah, ich habe eine Sache. Das ist von Stromberg, ne? Nein. Man wird sich schwarz ärgern. Nein, das ist von Stromberg. Oder was man schwarz sagt. Ich weiß nicht so schlecht. Ich habe eine Startup-Idee. Vielleicht unterstützt du mich da. Und zwar, wenn man im Bett liegt, hätte ich gerne so ein Gestell, wo man den Laptop einklinken kann, dass man im Liegen Netflix gucken kann, zum Beispiel im Bett. Mit dem Mac-Bas-Gerner. Mit dem Mac-Bas-Gerner. Ja, das habe ich auch dann nach 10. Aber Espa, das ist meine Idee. Pass auf Berlin. Meine Idee war eher, dass es ein bisschen leichter ist, ein bisschen vielleicht nicht so aufwendig, weil die haben so Kranhebelmechanismen drin, die das Ganze ein bisschen gross und unhandlich machen. Und wenn jeder einfach so ein Ding, was man so wegstellen kann, wie so ein Hocker, das wäre schön. Meine Seite ist, ich will sowas haben, weil auch oft aus so einem Bettliegen Gedanken herausgedacht. Jeder lag schon mal im Bett und dachte sich, wenn ich jetzt die Macht hätte, könnte ich mir diesen Oreo, der da irgendwie drüben neben dem Mülleimer liegt, könnte ich mir herziehen. Jetzt kommt die Greifzange. Warum nicht einfach so ein kleines Ding nehmen, aber das so kleine Pfeile verschiesst, die irgendwo entweder dran haften oder drin stecken und man dann so ein Draht zurückziehen kann. Das ist auch nicht so schwer zu machen. Ich meine, da muss halt nur irgendwie Kraft drin sein, da muss halt einen schönen Otto-Motor, einen schönen Diesel-Motor, du musst halt immer schön anreen. Und dann schießt du das Ding halt raus, vielleicht mit
Knallladung, Gas.
Oder so ein kleines Device,
oder so ein kleines Device, was du,
so ein kleiner Beamer, der an deiner
Zimmerdecke das Video
beamt.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Halt irgendwas,
irgendwas, das man im Liegen bleiben kann.
Ja, Innovation
ist, glaube ich, ein großes Stichwort
nächstes Jahr, glaube ich, da wird es
Vielen Dank. Halt irgendwas, irgendwas Neues, irgendwas, das man im Liegen bleiben kann. Ja, Innovation ist, glaube ich, ein großes Stichwort nächstes Jahr, glaube ich, da wird sich wirklich was tun. Oh, da wird sich wirklich was tun. Oh, da wird nächstes Jahr Leben im All entdeckt. Aber so nicht, dann wird die Bildwilder machen, oh, wir haben Aliens entdeckt und so, aber das sind die uncoole Art von Alien, so Bakterien oder sowas wird entdeckt, auf dem Mars oder sowas. Ja. Das kann man sich gut vorstellen. Das kann man sich sehr gut vorstellen. Ja. Ich glaube, man wird anfangen, Planeten zu verbinden. Man wird auf dem Mars eine große Öse anbringen, Projekt Öse, und dann einfach so eine riesige Metallöse in den Planeten lassen. In den Nasenringen. Und dann auch in die Erde und die einfach mal verbinden und einfach mal schauen, was passiert. Einfach sagen, Leute, scheiß mal auf alles andere, wir gucken jetzt mal, was passiert. Und eine grosse Kette von Erde zu Mars und die einfach aneinander hängen, wenn die ganz nah sind und dann gucken, was passiert. Aber auch so eine Kette, wo dann unten irgendwie Boss-Move oder so. So eine Goldkette, wo unten noch so was dranhängt, wo der Mond so denkt, wow, die sind ziemlich cool. Aber was würde passieren? Dann würden die aus der Umlaufbahn kommen und würde man dann All geschossen werden und was passiert dann? Ich finde klar, dass du gerade von einer Kette sprichst und von Planeten. Ja, aber wir würden auch, glaube ich, instant erfrieren. Ich glaube, wenn wir nur so 20 Zentimeter weiter von der Sonne weg sind, sind wir alle sofort tot. Das ist ein echtes Problem. Ja, das ist wirklich ein Problem, aber das habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden, weil der Abstand zur Sonne ist ja nicht das Problem, sondern die Erdkrümmung ist ja für die
Jahreszeiten und sowas halt.
Also der Abstand ist gar nicht so wichtig.
Doch, der ist schon sehr wichtig.
Nee, der Abstand ist, der Abstand ist
für die Jahreszeiten halt nicht zum Beispiel.
Weil du bist ja auch
Ja, nee, nicht für die Jahreszeiten.
Die Erde dreht ja auch keinen klaren Kreis um die Sonne,
sondern ellipsenförmig. Und wenn es da ein bisschen
weiter weg ist, ist es bei uns genauso warm, wie wenn es ein bisschen
näher dran ist. Nur die Jahreszeiten
... Die Erde dreht ja auch keinen klaren Kreis um die Sonne, sondern ellipsenförmig. Und wenn es da ein bisschen weiter weg ist, ist es bei uns genauso warm, wie wenn es ein bisschen näher dran ist. Nur die Jahreszeiten, heiß oder kalt, entscheidet halt die Erdkrümmung. Und das ist ganz, ganz, ganz seltsam, Leute. Leute, da muss was passieren 2017, das kann doch nicht weitergehen. Ich will die große, wir brauchen keine Jahreszeiten mehr, Initiative von Donald Trump haben. Jahreszeiten sind doch auch scheiße, vor allem ist doch auch ökonomisch Quatsch. Wenn man die Erdachse einfach mal entkrümmen könnte und dass sie einfach mal wieder gerade steht, da wäre immer Sommer und die Ernte könnte jedes Jahr viermal gemacht werden. Man könnte vier, also im Winter können ja viele Dinge nicht angebaut werden, so Äpfel kann man nicht gut machen, Kirschen sind nicht da und Himbeeren und sowas. Meine Lieblingsfrüchte. War auch doof. Das wäre halt doof. Und dann könnte man halt, wenn nur Sommer. Das wäre schön. Dann könnte man mit dem Bauchfall rumlaufen, wie den einen Tag, als es so warm war dieses Jahr, wurde Bauchfall rumgelaufen, bis ich Eis gegessen habe. Waldmeister-Eis mit Vanilleeis habe ich für mich entdeckt. Schön zwei Kugeln Eis vom Eismann.
Das ist schon toll.
Ich habe in dem Sommer ja dieses Jahr viel Frisbee draußen gespielt auf dem Hof und wir haben uns das Projekt ausgedacht.
Wir haben viele Frisbees über den Zaun geworfen,
viele Frisbees verloren. Viele seltsame
Nebenschauplätze entdeckt in Köln.
Aber das war schön, da haben wir uns kreativ
ein bisschen verwirklichen können. Ja, nichts davon umgesetzt,
aber wir haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge gegeben. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe mich
dieses Jahr kreativ mehr verwirklichet als in den anderen Jahren. Ja, das ist schön. das freut mich. Ja, das finde ich auch schön, das ist beruhigend. Ja. Für nächstes Jahr, da plane ich noch mehr. Wie geht es mit dem Podcast-Ufo weiter? Die Fans schreien nach einem Live-Auftritt? Ja, also nächstes Jahr, ich würde sagen, auf jeden Fall machen wir nächstes Jahr Live-Malphys. Wir machen ein Event. Ja. Wie dieses Event aussieht, ob es irgendwas, sagen wir mal, eher Jahrmarkteskes wird, ob es eine Schießbude wird, ob es Zuckerwatte wird oder ob es wirklich jetzt so ein Live-Event mit Zuschauern ist, wird sich zeigen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall, das können wir hier schon mal anversprechen, wenn es nicht ausgesprochen wird, dass wir hier ein Event starten werden. Eine Tombola. Bingo-Abend oder Tombola,
finde ich schon schön.
Nee, einfach eine Tombola,
die grosse Podcast-Ufo-Tombola.
Ja, Dart.
Dart.
Dart, wait.
Nochmal, Napoleon Bonner Dart.
Can't live with Dart, you.
Nope.
Das ist zu einem gewisser Dart.
Stop playing games with my Dart.
Die grosse Dart-Show.
Modern Dart.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Könnte man machen, ja.
Tombola hätte ich auch Lust.
Eine Ausstellung.
Was ist für dich die wichtigste Farbe bei einem Weihnachtsbaum? Also man muss hier entscheiden mit den Kugeln. Nimmt man einen grünen Baum oder einen blauen Baum? Richtig. Man muss hier auch dann irgendwann entscheiden, welche Kugel nimmt man und ist das Farbbild, ist die Farbpalette der Kugeln passend. Ich mag die silbernen. Ich finde silberne passen gut zu grün, silber und grün passen gut zusammen. Aber man müssen noch eine andere Farbe, eine Komplementärfarbe. Das ist klar. Das ist uns beiden klar. Ich bin ja immer für Rot. Bordeaux-Rot finde ich schön. Oder Gold, aber da passt bei Silber. Braun. Ich habe letztens gehört, dass es Menschen gibt, die vier so Farbzäpfchen haben. Weil der Mensch hat ja drei. So, der kann ja sehen, glaube ich, gelb, grün und rot oder irgendwie sowas.
Alle anderen Farben kann ich nicht sehen. Alle anderen Farben sehen eine Mischung. Das heißt, irgend so ein Viech hat zwei und kann zwei Farben sehen, der Mensch hat drei und kann dadurch tausend Farben sehen. Einfach weil man die mischen kann. Die zwei kann man ja auch mit.
Ja, aber es gibt tatsächlich durch Mutationen auch Menschen, die haben vier.
Die können also nochmal Potenz oder Wurzel oder was auch immer wesentlich mehr Farbe sehen als alle anderen. Das Problem ist nur, dass die Wissenschaftler davon ausgehen, dass sie das gar nicht merken, weil die das nicht lernen, weil die mit Leuten und Farben in der Hinsicht lernen, wie alle anderen Menschen auch und es dadurch gar nicht checken und es verkümmert, weil die das nie verwenden, diese Fähigkeit, aber die einfach enorm viel mehr Farben sehen. Und die kann man tatsächlich durch Blutproben herausfinden. Und Frauen haben die häufiger als Männer. Und da wurde tatsächlich mehrere Frauen gefunden, die diese zusätzlichen Farbzäpfchen haben. Dieses Jahr wurde man diese Farben. Dieses Jahr wurde eine Farbe auch entdeckt.
Echt?
Das sind auch so Dinge, die ich...
Violett oder was?
Nee, so eine Farbe entdeckt.
Leute, kommt mal kurz zusammen.
Ich habe hier was.
Leute, ich habe hier was.
Was ist das hier?
Was denn?
Ja, was ist das hier für eine Farbe?
What the f...
What?
Ja, hier, guckst du doch mal an.
Alter, was ist das denn?
Ich habe das noch nie gesehen. Was ist das denn für eine Farbe? So was habe ich noch nie gesehen. Es ist ein Anspitzler, da sind wir uns einig. Ja, ja, klar. Aber wie würdest du die Farbe beschreiben? Pelikan, aber was ... Vielleicht ... Ich glaube, das ist eine neue Farbe gefunden. Ja, und dann so war das, kann man sich das vorstellen. Spätät halbe Stunden weiter. Gute, alte Impro-Technik. War das nicht auch bei The Dress so? War das dieses Jahr? Ja. Nee, doch. Naja, bei diesem Kleid, wo manche sagten, das wäre Weissgold, manche dachten, das wäre blau-schwarz. Sowas ähnliches, ja. Aber da sind sich ja bis heute die Wissenschaftler nicht so ganz einig, was das eigentlich für eine Farbe hatte. Und warum manche das nicht sehen konnten undche das anders sehen konnten. Ja, ja, genau. Das ist auch so was. Vielleicht ist das das mit den Farbzäpfchen. Ja, kann sein. Auf jeden Fall haben die diese Blutproben alle gesammelt und die haben dann tatsächlich ein paar Frauen gefunden, die die haben und haben die dann besucht, die Wissenschaftler, aber die waren irgendwie gerade einkaufen oder so und konnten nicht. Ich glaube, Lebensmittelindustrie wird sich ja grossen Vortrag machen. Die werden nämlich entdecken, wie sie den Geschmack manipulieren können, wie sie den Geschmackszäpfchen-Stimulus so präparieren können, dass selbst sehr, sehr gesunde, leckere Sachen noch geballten Geschmack haben. Ja, ja, ja. Darauf würde ich mich freuen. Das wäre eine schöne Innovation. Das finde ich richtig gut. Nächstes Jahr wird es wieder im März geben, es wird wieder im April geben.
Eigentlich bleibt viele so wie es ist. Ja, die gleichen Monate.
Jedes Jahr. Toll. Kann man sich auch mal was anderes ausdenken.
Star Wars, alles neu.
Ja,
es gibt wieder einen neuen Jurassic Park,
einen neuen Star Wars. Das ist jedes Jahr so.
Jedes Jahr wird auch immer mehr
ritualisiert.
Auch die Popkultur.
Irgendwann ist es ein Zyklus. Wir wissen, morgen ist der 13. März, ach, heute kommt der nächste, wie jedes Jahr der neue Jurassic World raus. Ich hatte tatsächlich letzte Woche so eine Art Erleuchtung oder so. Ich habe mir erst Rogue One gesehen und den Film habe ich irgendwie nicht verdaut. Der ist mir irgendwie, ich konnte nicht verdauen, weil der hat so viele merkwürdige Dinge in mir ausgelöst, wo ich mir dachte, es läuft irgendwas richtig schief gerade. Irgendwas ist faul hier richtig. So wenn du in die Wohnung kommst und du hast so einen Hauch von einem Geruch und merkst, hier ist irgendwas gestorben drin. Und so war dieser Film auch, genau so war dieser Film auch, weil es alles so, man dachte sich dann, oh, das ist jetzt der coole Darth Vader Moment und man sich dachte, so habe ich früher nicht Filme geschaut, zu sagen so, oh, wann kommt der Darth Vader Moment und ja, das war so genau Darth Vader und so, ah ja, genau so richtig, so kennen wir ihn und das hat genau gepasst und man sich denkt so, so hat man früher nicht Filme geschaut, sondern da hat man einfach das genommen und jetzt nicht so, oh, ja, das passt überhaupt nicht zu den Rebellen, das so zu machen und so, das ist alles so wahnsinnig meta und analytisch und so. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich aber danach den neuen Jim Jarmusch-Film gesehen, mit Adam Driver, Patterson heißt der, der ein komplett weirder Film ist, der total ruhig ist, mega entspannt, gar nichts grossartiges erzählt, irgendwie nur so ganz vor sich hin rödelt und so, aber man so ganz wohlig ist und so. Auch diesen, der Film mich total berührt auf eine Art, aber ich konnte gar nicht so sagen, warum und ich wollte den gar nicht gross interpretieren oder jetzt gross, was will das alles heißen oder hier und da, sondern ich bin einfach so ein Kind und dachte mir einfach geil so, das ist irgendwie, hat mir, hat was mit mir getan und dachte, okay, cool, so sollten eigentlich Filme sein, so mal ein originelles Lebensgefühl, mal irgendwie so eine andere Welt eintauchen, ein anderes Leben eintauchen und nicht immer dieses, oh geil, jetzt ist jetzt genau der Prozessin-Layer-Moment und oh cool, die alten Geräusche und so. Das ist alles so wuselig irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Das war für mich so ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte, okay, ich muss mal wirklich meine, ich muss mal alles überdenken. Das Ding Film stirbt, also das Problem ist, Film stirbt ja gerade und zwar wird es ja auch, also die Leute lieben ja gerade Serien. Serien haben in den letzten Jahren so einen Boom erlebt. Serien, ja, waren auch ein grosses Ding. Und ja, dann geht es halt jetzt los, dass auch das Kino so ein bisschen übernimmt. Filme reichen Menschen nicht mehr und deswegen werden jetzt Cosmen gebaut. Es gibt den Harry Potter-Kosmos jetzt neu, es gibt den Star-Wars-Kosmos, es gibt den Marvel, den DC-Kosmos. Leute lieben das, augenscheinlich ist das gerade der neue heiße Scheiss. Man liebt es, Filme miteinander zu verschwurbeln und Leute wollen diese Anspielungen, Leute wollen, Momente sind wichtiger als Szenen. Ja, sie wollen halt vor allem Sachen essen, die sie schon mal gegessen haben, sie wollen Sachen haben, die sie kennen, weil einfach, ich glaube, diese Produzentensicht, die Produzentensicht ist, ja, aber das ist ja klar, darum geht's ja. Ja genau, und das ist aber das Problem,... Ich glaube, mir fehlt Mut in diesem Jahr, hat mir Mut gefehlt und ich wünsche mir für nächstes Jahr, wünsche ich mir Mut. Gibt kreativen Leuten Freiheit, Dinge zu tun? Aber darum geht es nicht. Nein, das Problem ist, Filme sind zu teuer. Es gibt einfach eine große Kluft, es gibt einfach nur noch die fucking riesigen Blockbuster-Filme, die alle so brutal teuer sind, dass jeder, der da mit Mut kommt, sagt, ja, haha, Mut, wenn das Ding nicht läuft, verlieren wir alle unseren Job. Weil jeder Film so fucking teuer ist, dass er einfach ganze Studios in den Abgrund stürzen kann. Du musst für jeden Film erstmal mehrere Millionen Euro Marketing, völlig egal, was der Inhalt ist, scheiß drauf. Das stimmt. Du musst erst 200 Millionen Euro Marketing und wie viel der Film dann kostet, der Film kostet dann nochmal so viel, aber das ist dann eigentlich relativ irrelevant, weil du brauchst erstmal so viel Marketing, um diesen reizüberfluteten Markt überhaupt noch an Land zu kommen. Aber das brauchst du ja bei jedem Film. Und dann muss der Film so eine sichere Bank sein, dass da auf gar keinen Fall im ersten Wochenende irgendeine ganz furchtbare Kritik kommt. Deswegen machst du lieber einen passablen Film, als einen richtig guten Film zu versuchen, der dann vielleicht scheitert. Das ist doch klar. Du gehst nicht mehr all in, weil es sich einfach nicht mehr lohnt, weil du zu viel, weil die Steaks zu hoch sind. Und es gibt diesen Middle Ground einfach nicht mehr. Es gibt dann diese ganz
kleinen Indie, die total abfacken und crazy sind,
aber so diesen normalen, mittleren Filmen
ist immer weniger. Manche Filme schaffen das ja,
und da meine ich einen Trend zu erkennen.
Sowas wie Swiss Army Man Lobster.
Das ist einfach so ein cooler Indie-Charakter,
der gerade kommt. Absolut, ja, aber die muss man suchen
und finden, und die haben keine grossen Zahlen.
Die werden nicht belohnt.
Doch, Filme haben schon eine grosse Zahl.
Natürlich können die nicht mithalten und so.
Also das Ding ist, Absolut, ja, aber die muss man suchen und finden und die haben keine grossen Zahlen. Die werden nicht belohnt.
Doch, Filme haben schon eine gewisse Zahl. Natürlich können die nicht mithalten und so. Das Ding ist nur, alle Filme, die man sich gerade anguckt, sind halt Intellectual Property von was Größerem. Einfach, die haben eine Bank, die haben eine Grundgesamtheit an Leuten, wo Produzenten sicher gehen können, dass sie da ins Kino gehen werden, mit einer grossen Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und ja, da muss man, glaube ich, ein bisschen gegenwirken
als Konsument, einfach nicht in
Filme gehen, in die man nicht unbedingt reingehen will.
Aber das ist für mich
die Schattenseite vom Aufstieg des Nerds.
Wir haben in den letzten Jahren erlebt,
der Nerd wird immer Mainstreamiger, Superhelden,
Comics dominieren, was ich hätte niemand
vorstellen können, dass Comic-Helden
das Uncoolste, was es überhaupt gibt, plötzlich absoluter Mainstream ist und ihr sich dafür interessiert. Der Tod von Superman damals war in den Nachrichten. Das war einfach ein Riesending. In Zeiten von Comic-Buchern. Ja, ganz früh. Ja gut, ganz früh, als es nichts gab. Aber jetzt sag ich mal so, als wir klein waren oder aufgewachsen sind, oder sowas, ja gut, weiss nicht, das ist halt so krass dominant, ist glaube ich nicht. Der Aufsteht der Nerds führt dann auch so... Und das analytische Gucken. Ja, zu diesem ekelhaften Ne, Ne, Ne, Ne, und dieses Anspielungen und es muss sich alles wiederholen und man Comfort Food und ich will genau das und das ist einfach nicht mehr so dieses... Irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass da so eine unglaubliche Starrheit im Denken entstanden ist, die sich nicht mehr auf was wirklich völlig Neues einlassen wollen, weil man alles enttäuscht ist. Und wir haben ja beide gleichzeitig gesagt, nach Rogue One hatten wir so Bock auf die Prequels. Ja. Und ich habe noch nicht
geguckt, aber ich habe so Lust, ich habe da gestern so kurz
vor Episode 1 oder 2 zu gucken. Ja, weil die
komischerweise wesentlich mutiger und experimenteller
sind. Die sind eine komplette Fehlschläge.
Ja. Aber man merkt, okay, da
irgendwie neue Welten mit den Gungens,
die Gungens sind eine ganz eigene Welt und die führen
einen eigenen Krieg. Eine furchtbare Welt.
Die sind alle schlecht, aber es ist besser als dieses
hundertmal wiedergekaute. Ja, man
hat irgendwie Bock darauf, aber das ist ja gerade
und das ist ja auch eine alte philosophische
Vielen Dank. Das ist eine furchtbare Welt. Dies ist alles schlecht, aber es ist besser als dieses hundertmal wiedergekaute auf der Art. Man hat irgendwie Bock darauf, aber das ist ja gerade und das ist ja auch eine alte philosophische Denkweise, dass man Dinge überkompensiert. Hat es nicht Hegel auch gesagt? Die Geschichte lehrt einem doch, dass man überkompensiert. Und die ganze Zeit ist es wie so eine Sisu-Dinoskurve, die langsam die Mitte findet und das ist doch gerade, wir befinden uns einfach gerade in der Welt, man hat, bei den Prequels hat man die, ist das Experiment nach hinten losgegangen, so jetzt geht man wieder in Richtung Fanservice, in Richtung, wir geben den Leuten das, was sie wollen. So, jetzt in Episode 8, bin ich mir sicher, wir jetzt wieder in eine andere Richtung gehen. Und dann geht es so langsam, vielleicht zieht das aus, man findet es in der Mitte. Da bin ich der festen Überzeugung. Aber ja, also es ist kreativ ganz spannend, was die Industrie,
ja, also die Kreativindustrie ist für mich eh auch ein Oxymoron, geht einfach auch nicht
zusammen, weil
Zahlen, das ist schwierig. Da haben wir ja auch unsere eigene Erfahrungen,
das ist natürlich immer schwierig, aber
Kreativität kostet Geld,
Kreativität kostet halt Geld,
und Geld zieht auch eine
grosse Verantwortung mit sich einfach, und da
muss man wissen, wie man damit umgeht, das ist ja auch eine Art Währung, Und da muss man gucken, wie man damit umgeht. Und das wirkt natürlich auch Risiken, die keiner gehen will, das ist klar. Und keine Ahnung, wohin das führt, ich habe echt keine Ahnung. Es kann auch nicht weiterführen. Es kann ja nicht den 800. Marvel-Film geben. Das wird ja nicht versieden. Mal sehen, das wird schon eine Menge angekündigt für nächstes Jahr. Und ich sehe auf Nine-Gags schon wieder die Posts, oh, wie geil wird das nächste Jahr, so mit 120 Releases, von wo ich mir denke, Moment mal, auf der anderen Seite beschweren sich alle alles wieder wieder gekaut, aber es gibt die große Masse, sagt noch, oh, das wird ein richtig geiles Jahr und dann posten die halt wirklich Listen, irgendwie X-Men, X-Men 8, X-Men 9, X-Men 10, wo denen nicht mal selber auffällt, dass das doch scheiße ist. Aber auch ich freue mich auf Justice League. Auch ich werde in Justice League gehen. Ich habe da keinen Bock drauf. Da habe ich Bock drauf. Das ist halt leider einfach ein Problem. Die Universen sind halt cool und die sind irgendwann, sind die ausgekürt, aber gut. Ja. Bist vielleicht weiter, bist älter, bist erwachsener. Du bist erwachsener geworden in diesem Jahr. Ja. Das stimmt schon. Wir waren auf Spotify, wir sind auf Spotify gekommen. Wir haben eine Menge neue Hörer erschlossen. Freut uns auf jeden Fall. Schön, dass ihr mit uns auf diesem Weg gegangen seid. Wir entlassen euch jetzt erstmal in eine längere Pause. Also natürlich hat er eine Weihnachtspause. Weihnachtspause, ganz normale. Kommt mal ein bisschen runter, relaxt, einfach mal ein bisschen, nehmt euch mal ein bisschen Auszeit, kommt mal irgendwie woanders rein und irgendwie malt mal ein schönes Gedicht oder so und kommt mal ein bisschen runter. Ja, und wie gesagt, ich finde das, das finde ich ganz gut von dir, dass du zur Originalität aufgerufen hast. Einfach mal, also muss man alle ein bisschen nächstes Jahr individuell sein. Bisschen weniger wiederholen, weniger Running Gags, weniger alles konstant. Und mehr man selbst sein. Brutal wiederholen. Jeder Mensch will doch, dass es am Anfang, wenn man noch jünger ist, will man gerne sein wie alle anderen. Man will passen, man will ins Gefüge passen, man will die Klasse passen. Irgendwann merkt man aber, dass Individualität das ist, was sich das Leben lebenswert macht. Und deswegen, lass uns mal alle müssen Origineller sein. Auf jeden Fall. Man selbst sucht eure Mitte und dann gehen wir nächstes Jahr in eine schöne neue Zeit.
Herr Tietze, es war ein schönes Jahr.
Vielen Dank, auch ich freue mich.
Dankeschön.
Und ich freue mich auf das nächste Jahr und wohin der Wind uns noch wehen mag. songs of angry men is the music of the people who will not be slaves again when the beating